[Music]
The Blind Auditions on The Voice
continued as two standout contestants
score some massive praise I grew up in a
musical family the Cassidy family my my
grandma Shirley Jones from the Partridge
Family
eighteen-year-old Jack Cassidy landed a
spot on Team Alisha no one is more
excited about it than his famous grandma
[Music]
shirley jones tells ET quote i'm
incredibly proud of jack
I believe his natural soulfulness and
incredible range make him a standout on
Tuesday we met 23-year old Malik des
Vosges a young father with a dream I
just want you to move about it for this
opportunity right here me means he means
everything to me
malik saying miguel's sure thing his
vocals impressed we can do it baby
simple and plain is this lovely the
short thing
[Music]
coach Adam Levine turned his chair and
Malik got even more emotional sit in my
chair just go through my chair
so you feet up on there come on I'm just
a guy from Washington DC just trying to
do what's best for my daughter
yes and she's back there with my mom
[Applause]
[Music]